en fait pour dérouler lorsque les
longtemps mais non mais non c'est
d'attaquer improbable
et dans le même temps un autre groupe
armé à chaque édifice
major de l'armée burkinabè les combats
ont été intenses et ont duré plusieurs
heures durant lesquelles dédié aux
éléphants de se parler de bilan et je te
promets théorique neutraliser enfin le
motoriste allemand a été payée par les
forces de sécurité pour que la baie
néanmoins on déplore cette mort s'il
battait ce qu'il fait du côté des forces
dans les bottines avait
un grand nombre de ces victimes étaient
des déplacés
[Applaudissements]
le royal
oui il
est naturel de
[Musique]
laval a
attaqué chez les
elle a dit qu'elle l'avait bien d'elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bon
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
je vais
surprenant
à
[Musique]
et
qui est venu c'est la seule localité
d'un burkina pour n'est pas dit dans le
monde on a des craintes
traditionnellement avec une architecture
différente des autres
navets les guides y avait les
différentes familles qu'on visite et où
chacun gagne quelque chose il y avait
les petits restaurants et petite buvette
où les clients c'est un peu partout
chacun gagne 1 puis son compte je
pouvais
par jour avoir plus
cinq groupes
5 gouttes de touristes avec des 4 4 qui
vient du de partout
soit doit garder il souffre nous voulons
comme guide on nous avait commandé ou
souffrent
et donc ça vivait et je me faisais plein
d'amis
aujourd'hui
ceux des larmes aux yeux
au départ
on me dit taylorisme kiabi sont
des larmes aux yeux pas que pour moi
pour tout ceux grecques sete galles
population
qui vit du ca
je
depuis que le tourisme y arrêter tout le
monde s'abat sur le site minier
il alors c'est une zone très très
dangereux
personne n'utilise la joule même l'état
c'est le far west
c'est chacun couchois
il volait son sen fou
[Musique]
parent
ben brik
par la belle vous
la boîte ou à la faune et ça m'a trop
tout
animal on dit quand tout le monde
sera mis fin
à canal
alpha blondy comme amd passe bien mais
mieux il met à kraft lahm du programme à
une tournée arrivée pour moi nollet kébé
ni akbar cinq ans des hiboux
comme la tonte
unités
noir
alésia
bob
il s'adapte à toutes les situations
au début je les ai connus comme apprenti
de camions je suivais les véhicules les
transporteurs à un moment donné
il s'est décidé de rentrer au village il
sait donner au tourisme à fond la caisse
il vendait l'artisanat mme
rivas et objets d'art ou touriste mais
tout le monde pouvait lui parce qu'il a
une manière d'accueil
des clients il est annie à tel point
aussi qu'ils ne voulaient même pas
l'objet tu l'achètes 150 parce qu'il est
phénoménal
[Musique]
mais médias disney le terrorisme
voilà tout d'un coup tient plus du
tourisme
même moment où
il n'avait plus sa fin et les partis du
lycée
[Musique]
quoi faire
il a tenté par tous quel cuvée la saison
n'a pas été bonne
il n'a rien vu comme en revue
un moment donné c'est décidé je vais à
la mine on a dit bob tu pourrais il a
dit oui je vais ici la chasse les tenter
ma chance il est parti
laissez les enfants tout seuls dans la
maison
les thalys partie sa chance
la première fois quand il est allé il
est revenu bredouille
j'ai dit mais bolt doit pas abandonner
c'est très dangereux mais c'est très
dangereux si je viens en vie qu'est ce
que je fais tu là si je peux pas passer
tout le montant demandé aux gens pour
aller nourrir mes enfants
je prends le risque
julie sq pour les enfants on quitte à
eux de payer puisque les papas ne
restent pas là bas parce que c'est pour
eux que je fais ça
je dis ok ils me disent tu vois y en a
qui ont la chance qu'ils sortent avait
des millions moi j'ai pas encore eu ma
chance peut-être un jour ça viendra
non
[Musique]
oh
une grande la
première à la
nema
enyeama
y en a
2 comme manu à bannir locales et
catherine rougeot ben mahmoud al saad
hayel ouvert
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
des sols est déjà l'un des otages
aujourd'hui on dit arrête
ta rue ligaments
gt gt cantal qui est dépendante ou et
l'ol était content nous étions en
contact
quentin vous était content et là et
l'horaire était content à
ces pratiques
c'est simple si je vu qu'on a dû vivre
là
on se car tu es là tu viens me voir
je te féliciter ce que j'ai regardé mon
bel ordinateur et r je me suis rendu
compte que tu es le deuxième meilleur
élève excellence donc ça quand même je
suis vraiment très très fier de toi
à la maison comment ça va devenir papa y
travaille beaucoup et ouais donc ça veut
dire qu'ils par plusieurs jours quelques
fois
c'était plus facile tu as vite en
motivant mené l'artisanat où c'est plus
facile maintenant quand il va c'est un
voyage
non et à tous les plans des problèmes
d'embrayage avec quel genre de problème
un des 5 et celle d'un crime là à lavau
qu'il ya des gens qui veulent pas couper
en travailleur
toi est-ce que tu as un rêve dans la vie
est ce que tu veux faire un métier
qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras adultes mon cher ami je les aime
travailler à l'école à l'école et puis
après
[Musique]
ah qu'est ce que tu voudrais faire dans
thérèse
quel métier tu voudrais faire
elle a battu
à mort
à la fois et ont durablement installé la
peur des frères ils arrivent en moto et
massacre des enfants débarquent dans des
marches et tourisme humanitaire dans le
même temps dans des comptes étrangers il
finit en sus de leur forfait et où les a
connus les figues des plus barbares sous
le prétexte de la religion and roll des
jeunes désoeuvrés actif dans quelques
subsides et promettent la fille pepy
leur objectif idéologique personne ne
peut la lire il annonce d'ailleurs que
quand malgré des impressionnants moyens
des armées coalisées contre eux ils
continuent de s'aimer peur et désolation
dans la sous région mais qui font ces
terroristes qui attendent l'ordre du
peuple huit années maintenant que faire
[Musique]
ce qui est très inquiétant pour moi
on constate qu'ils
sont cons beaucoup de terrain
du jour au lendemain ce que les shops
est arrivé on ne sait pas quand parce
que comme ils sont pas maîtrisés si les
grandes puissances ne connaît pas leur
position pour les arrêter c'est pas nous
paysans appliquant paye comme ça qui est
ainsi
même le téléphone ne marche pas là c'est
pas nous autres qui pourrait
contrecarrer la juge
[Musique]
claire
oh
bien
voilà miss avr map m
[Applaudissements]
sakho
s'est toujours
partout des milices
d'autodéfense
communément appelé l'udc au louvre où
commençait à un point la sécurité de
leur zone
ils sont pas le connu par l'état
ils sont auto non
seulement je mettais beaucoup opposé les
sensations sur le coup si j'étais pas
pour ils se sont installés
[Applaudissements]
ces tracassé par ci par là parce que
quand on voit
des vidéos de comment les ampoules ouvre
une tête
les gens quand ils appellent ça faisait
peur
c'est dépaysant des gens qui ne sont pas
là l'école il sait pas que tant tué
quelques lui vole à présent
que c'est interdit il sait pas les
attentes tout ça
à part quelques
parce que tu es et je colle aux mureaux
c'est normal qu'ils connaissent pas ça
[Musique]
art
alors maintenant si tu peux voler un
pool est utile de rappeler combien voilà
un poulet oui ça commence wariner et
angola qui vole un oeuf et la amende de
515 milles c'est nice a émis une poule
trente mille cinq cents mais il a des
censures on va le fouetter correctement
on va le fouetter
l'association nous allons la tâche est
maintenant pour nous même si il a bouffé
médicaments comme en commun notre totem
c'est on enlève le triplé de bois les
bois la sela bois des dix comme ça n'a
rien donné mais voilà le wallonie
notamment des tamarins voilà camara à la
merci au feu il ya une autre technologie
aussi nous allons écouter un bois divisé
en deux attaché avait un corps dessous
au niveau de sa jambe si c'est bien
c'est tout ce qu'il y arriver tout vomi
il ya un autre plat aussi qu'on
l'appelle le montage par avion
nous avions aussi ses véritables ce
qu'ils y arrivent à détails rien à
cacher
voilà sécurité du pays puis 9 ouais
[Musique]
bien peu lire
les uns aux autres
voilà
[Musique]
le coeur
agne
qu'on appelle un coup
après année
allen overy
à tous les combattants
[Musique]
du
hamas
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
global
voilà
qui
revient
[Musique]
ce soir pour la vienne
[Applaudissements]
bah voilà
[Musique]
la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
la base et je
vois
et
wayne
rooney qui
avait dit non
auj
[Applaudissements]
la
campagne est elle même sur canal malgré
des longueurs d'onde dans des ananas
brute s'élève à 6 poitiers
location non
utilisation trouvent privés l'outil les
inimitiés aux biens et à 2 0 un peu
partout et à la langue on leur apprend à
marcher deux chambres de recoller dans
trop
élitiste dont quatre dans la poule à
laval et puis l'a fait au
grand jour en russie chez ces jeunes à
l'az l'an prochain 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'or est en train de remplacer tous
actuellement dans le village qui tu es
dans leurs
pas deux beaucoup de levure
et nord d'ailleurs une fois qu'il sort
du trou qui l'a beaucoup d'argent il
s'en fout il achète au prix qu'il veut
et c'est comme ça puis tapez ti ça
attire tout le monde
un jeune qui va aujourd'hui
qui a la chance de tomber sur le silo et
qui gagnent des cailloux ils tombent
dans l'or à moins d'une des mois on
apprend qu'il s'est acheté une grosse
moto
ceux qui voulaient pas aller
alors tout de suite jeudi matin il n'est
pas plus fort que moi et puis il est
allé là il s'agit d'une moto moi aussi
je vais y aller et c'est comme ça ça
attire les jeunes là-bas à la mine c'est
ça le fait de voir son camarade qui a
été
qui a gagné un peu inutile valérie
charles tentation c'est pour ça tout le
village se vide vers la bas
[Musique]
karoubi
de cannes
mazouz
pas
c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
ça
[Musique]
ma
faim
[Applaudissements]
voilà
voilà en colère
quoi de voir
à
honeyboy zemmourienne
la manche à la nage en
balade
au
lac
encore
un
maroilles a au nom selon d'entre eux
anna gavalda
loyaux à tokyo à nay et
[Musique]
et concourir clôturé
moyennant quoi il en retourne et
à madeco vidéo
non covin
[Musique]
la santé a beaucoup de mal à ça vous
serez lui remet un troc aux conquois le
comté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guy à la moitié l'état
par les babyloniens
ok ok
[Musique]
non
entretien
[Musique]
je
le
[Musique]
on
mais que
voilà
manama
[Musique]
dai a toi jéjé vihear
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devant l'autre
nous avons
ce n'est pas vraiment un scénario
brillant de cacher
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
comme lundi mardi mercredi
sagan donc non
voilà
alors
grant
voilà c'est une guitare
blog de paul et le gall
le verdict est la leur
à l'égard
des niveaux pied de page
là on est bas
[Musique]
chez eux
bon voilà
après
[Musique]
bouazza
mozart
[Musique]
waouh
alors
riot
je
pot commun voilà
[Musique]
à la traîne
oui
[Musique]
ces jihadistes
quand ils se rencontrent et à la
pauvreté qui rentre dans la zone ils
essaieront d'utiliser cela qu'il veut
avec leurs moyens parce qu'ils sont
affamés pour les recruter quand ils vont
se rendre compte
aussi
qu on est chacun par ci par là et a plus
d'union
chacun ça c'est leur force de frappe
donc
qu'elle avait signé pour ce village
cette question reste posée
[Musique]
je
n'arrivais moi c'est ouais ça va donc l'
ena de
une à deux une bière à deux pas ça va la
police va placer en tout cas pas du tout
pas du tout seulement pour moi c'est pas
où aller j'essaie de l'entrée
nous qui travaille vraiment si tu sais
et vu que je dois le faire si ça ne
plaît pas
souvent au film que des tabacs naturel
du coin c'est l'alcool pur et s est vu
qu'il faut vraiment
abandonné mais là bas c'est l'avis de
laquelle tu peux avoir du courage pour
rentrer sans quoi aussi sur jésus de
l'entrée mention mains de 5,6 millions
dans un sac rouge est là vendu de
l'entrée 5 citations
parmi 10 il ya peut être huit qui va pas
des saints
ouais
mais un chien joue je gagne l'argent
pour terminer ma maison quand je suis le
lieu de l'élevage
c'est à dire que je m'installe pour
faire le le vase
là je n'aurai plus au site même s'ils
s'attendent du diamant
je reste calée à la maison je pense que
l'éducation de moi mes enfants ma
famille est mieux que ça
voilà
partir à l'éire je suis de l'argent nous
ça ne m'est jamais venu à l'idée
j'ai aimé la culture de mon village
depuis mon jeune âge
actuellement mon linge et la vieille qui
est la maman qui est là si je parle à
l'essai qu'est ce qu'elle deviendra
je suis prêt à rester pour tout ce qui
va réduire
pour tout ce qui va arriver je reste je
ne bouge pas du village je reste là
jusqu'à
moi ça suive
[Musique]
à
e
on
tu en as beau temps s'y tenait
mais
tous quelqu'un pour qui la vie ne vous a
pas
bon ya pas mal un beau la warm pool des
meilleures variétés dit que ça je le dis
comme ça c'est le temps commence à quand
une amie pendu ou house a écrite et
angelo akon
[Musique]
non sans avoir des banques et ne ratez
pas avant midi dans le tarn
nous
désole vrai tu m'as grand
talent et une team tony et moi tant
mieux dans la loi comme un déboire y
autorise
[Musique]
et
où
lui
[Musique]